the mother calling for justice for her
son nearly two years later police say
19-year-old james leppe was shot and
killed in december of 2020. now his
mother says she wants to see charges
filed in connection with his death
he was such a good boy it's been a year
and a half since joanna velez has seen
her son james lepe every day i think
about my son when i wake up when i go to
sleep she calls him a gentle respectful
soul who had a bright future ahead of
him that he never got to see through his
parents worst nightmare police say the
19-year-old was shot in the chest and
killed in december of 2020 during a
confrontation with his sister's
boyfriend at this apartment complex near
tropicana and decatur it's the worst
thing that i'll ever go through and it
will forever haunt me velez says this
stemmed from a domestic violence
situation her son was trying to stop and
believes the entire thing could have
been prevented any woman that goes
through this
has the courage to be able to walk away
because things like this can't be undone
but more than anything after all this
time she's still hoping to see justice
served as she says no charges were filed
in her son's death i'll never be able to
be the same person that i was i lost the
most important thing in my life she
hopes she can try to move forward and
begin to heal with some semblance of
closure i couldn't have asked for a
better son
and i lost it
according to court records the man velez
says is connected to her son's death
face several felony domestic battery
charges in july of last year